Selena Gomez makes a donation to the
times up initiative with her salary from
a rainy day in New York I think people
are gonna be a little surprised a source
close to the 25 year old singer confirms
to ET she made a significant donation
anonymously that quote far exceeded her
salary on the upcoming Woody Allen movie
Selena has received some major backlash
for starring in the flick even from her
mom Mandy TP who spoke out on Instagram
writing a comment to one user who
believes Selena should apologize for
choosing to work with the famed director
quote no one can make Selena do anything
she doesn't want to I had a long talk
with her about not working with him and
it didn't click no matter how hard you
try to advise it falls on deaf ears
starring in one of Allen's films has
been a controversial choice for actors
for years reignited in 2014 when his
daughter Dylan Farrow went public with
accusations that he molested her as a
child Allen has denied the allegations
and investigations into the matter have
resulted in no charges against the
filmmaker
[Music]